it's not just Russia is it a lot of
other countries are starting to see the
West America and its allies in this way
China does to a certain extent the bric
countries do and a lot of these
countries talk about a geopolitical
Tipping Point where American hegemony is
coming to an end and we're moving into a
multilateral world
and it's obvious to them
that the culture was if you like are a
sign of
Western weakness
have you seen any evidence of other
countries trying to stoke the culture
wars in order to prove that the West is
in Decline
sure I mean there have been some
interesting pieces especially during the
rise and the demonstrations of 2020 of
China developing Bots and hiring
individuals to post on social media
accounts to stoke contentious debate and
to troll people and to essentially uh
cultivate hostility and animosity
between Americans and this is in their
interest to do so